critic critics excitement and blue
critic he's questioned things like that
fashion glittering heads every critic
he's truly truly truly truly truly truly
truly truly truly truly truly truly
truly of critic critics my name as we
clearly explained hey yeah we're in this
working this hey and we're in it I don't
care cuz I follows through these I met
you before critic create a did you get
the part I'm saying critic my name
critic well in our first cinematic
motion picture that we're gonna show to
the world yes we're gonna use our
hologram computers to disguise who we
really are why I don't know but we got
keep this life changing technology a
secret and only use it to sing songs and
take down another competing bands Oh
like the misfits are the stingers no and
we'll do it while supporting my 12
foster kids 12 foster kids I was very
inspired by Brangelina and if we have
time maybe just maybe we'll talk about
movies well what are we waiting for
yeah slap that pointless music video
credit below and let's get glittering
[Music]
um cut we told you you're not allowed to
say cut because you're not directing
this yes the chart made that quite clear
I just don't feel like this is what
people are gonna be looking for with a
nostalgia critic theatrical release this
isn't really what the show is about
trust me we worked on the gem movie yes
and if there's anything we figured out
it's that people want adaptations with
eighties music Holograms and truly
outrageous adventures are you sure
that's not what they just wanted for a
gem movie I don't understand
can you phrase your question in the form
of a chart I can't understand him
through his accent why don't we take a
break for all of us to collect our
thoughts good idea I'll calculate the
probability of me relaxing huh zero does
this feel right to you I don't know I
mean the chart says thank you I mean
this is what they think the mass
audience wants we should at least try it
have you seen the gem movie well for the
sake of this analogy to work I'll say no
why don't you watch it first
the original Jem and the Holograms was a
slightly dated 80s cartoon just just
lightly it sound around the singer who
led a double life using technology from
a supercomputer named synergy to use
Holograms and her earrings to disguise
herself it was it was Jim which is more
than I can say for the movie the film is
quickly being regarded as one of the
worst adaptations of all time
not only do viewers frequently saw that
the trailer virtually had nothing to do
with the original source material but so
few people saw it that it was pulled
from theaters in literally two weeks
weeks that's faster than when we figured
out Saddam Hussein might be a bad guy it
was ignored by the masses panned by the
critics and despised by true fans of the
original show is it worth all the hatred
well spike up your hair and ignore that
little voice in your head saying this is
wrong this is Jem and the Holograms
we're still here so you are oh yeah miss
Yulan nope have a nice review grams
you'll notice that this movie was made
by bh productions known primarily for
making horror films that's so easy I'm
just gonna give you a pass on that joke
movie but you better have tougher
material for me later we open with
performer and famed sharknado star
Aubrey Peeples playing Jerrica who is
making a video about how she became Jim
my little sister came her now you know
how some people go online and overshare
every tiny little detail of her life is
just an open ebook with everyone to see
yeah tell me more about how your sister
shares everything in this two-hour video
about how you became a star you know a
movie I'll let this one pass - in fact
give me the first tip you can have the
first hint it's okay great now I had to
be relentless Anya she lives with her
aunt Molly Ringwald no really
Molly Ringwald is in this I'll give you
two seconds to let out a little cry oh
okay who has two foster daughters and
according to Jerrica there's only one
missing piece my dad because like in all
bad movies dead mothers don't mean
he would call me he
is diamond-in-the-rough or his jem spell
with a j' he specifically said that
every time he's working on a device
called synergy
yep that's the supercomputer from the
show don't blink or you'll confused
which one is which and by the way they
never do say what he died of but by look
ed is incredibly deteriorating health
you know it just had to be broad
shoulder itis you know the same time
sure took her mother that doesn't exist
I still feel like he's with me
oh by the way that's not the title
they're just reminding you that you are
watching Jem and the Holograms you
didn't wander into the wrong theater no
I know what you're thinking
this many girls under one roof recipe
for disaster right well if you're
thinking that that's sexist you should
be ashamed of yourself yeah they do
non-sexist things like get in arguments
about what clothes to wear isn't my
favorite skirts but it's almost like a
36 year old man wrote this I don't want
to look like a fashion refugee from 1985
let's just measure the frustration every
pissed off gym fan must be having with
say oh really pissed off gym fan with
her hair serving as a mood ring Oh trust
me you can't see a lot of her but it's
okay because they solve all their
problems by humming in harmony no really
no matter what the issue is that always
seems to solve everything
Kimber hid a c-note seriously yeah
seriously let's go I know that I messed
up and I'm sorry I'm here creator
Mascagni the eye with the pen well you
should have taken the last night coke
that was my diet cool camera hey let's
see note what are you talking about whoo
I'm definitely not following this
we should probably get him to a hospital
I may literally have seconds that's more
like it
now get your cold clothes off we're
heading Coulee tonight so they decide to
do a music video just for fun and for
some reason think they're in a found
footage movie because they literally
film everything they do
[Music]
okay is this film's goal to make every
previous generation hate this generation
[Music]
truly truly courageous Oh what they all
want your cut to sing no I feel
uncomfortable
come on Jay I need you I think you need
her the same way your scrambled eggs
need more salt kinda but can live
without it but things suddenly get
forcibly serious when it looks like the
house is going to be foreclosed on I
guess it looks like Molly Ringwald
doesn't make the best money choices I
mean she's in this film isn't she 30
days that's what they're giving us I
mean there has to be something that we
can do there is we can be strong for
each other if there's anything three
stooges media has taught me is that
entertainment always saves heartfelt
buildings so she decides to film a video
and I'm not even kidding
she does that thing where she films the
intro like a million times I'm gonna
play you a song that I wrote
obviously oh oh hey didn't see you there
I need to cook this oh she's shy the
movies give you permission to be an
egomaniac later because we know deep
down you're really shy and finally she
disguises herself in a wig and
low-lighting calling herself Jem maybe
I'm alone out here and nobody's living
Christ am I the only one waiting from
Hofstra to pop up any minute yeah I'm
the only one I've voice Susan went so
scary now that's Gary I'm in the dark ID
what if one mom no you're not alone will
you shut up or try to sleep Jerrica of
course wants to delete the video but her
sister uploads it and literally goes
viral overnight all the web's been
talking about is this video posted by an
artist who only goes by Jem somebody on
acoustic guitar singing about how
they're alone I have never seen this
online but every time i refresh it it
just keeps going up even the head of a
music label called starlight is wanting
to make her a star
Jem if you're out there check your inbox
how do they think this works if I make a
video of myself judging off and then
posted online is someone gonna be like I
want to make you face oh how they
scoffed but cherica's said that she has
a huge money-making opportunity laid out
for her oh poor freaking baby think you
have the potential to become something
so much greater the version of me that
they want doesn't it doesn't exists
again I think that's what most of the
fanbase has been saying but Iran
convinces her to talk to the agent all
while this entirely pointless YouTube
video plays
[Music]
what is the purpose of this are they
preparing a punchline drumbeat when she
says she wants to bring her sisters in
the agent writes by oh wait I take it
back she doesn't write by she writes puh
sorry I always miss type driver will
pick everyone up in the a.m. with puh
why are those two keys always together
morning good morning so they're picked
up by a driver / bodyguard
my name is zipper oh and since we got
the feeling you didn't hate the movie
enough yet here's Juliette Lewis sure
thank or is that someone in a Juliette
Lewis mask no no that's her that's her
she plays Erica the owner of starlight
studios who's supposed to hammer in the
message that big artistic corporations
are bad a special thanks to this big
artistic corporate film for telling us
that
which reminds me Twitter Instagram
tumblr all of that until further notice
none of it oh oh sorry I just assumed
that's what happens we tell millennial
that hard as it may seem to believe this
movie has a clothing montage I know I so
rarely see them too but America's gonna
turn them in to the Jonas sister she has
a lot of work ahead of her but it's okay
because she has an intern / son named
Rio ah who's been hollered to keep an
eye on them skylight mansion room is
upstairs
this is your room no no what was that
slow-mo curtain thing you're in a
mansion and you focus on the being
amazed by the curtains it's a matter
with you
does anyone else so tire they can't even
take their shoes off I'm so tired I
can't even climb long ones on yeah it's
hard having people do your makeup and
try dresses on
what are you 40 that's something go suck
in the night as they hear a sound from
Jericho's bag yeah thanks for the
reminder
I was confusing it with all the other
robots I saw on this movie sure that
someone communicates through music the
exact opposite of what Nickelback does
so map to Luke Skywalker this sucker has
everything so okay screw the band her
dad has created life obviously they can
sell this thing and make more than
enough money to save the house me that's
where your dad wants us to take center
genex you're right or go to the place
you're I trashcan chori for a second
what is clearly makes no sense how about
another pointless youtube video to have
it make even less sense yeah yeah they
still think there's a connection somehow
to what's going on in the movie and just
random videos found online where the
makers of this film just like so they
steal Rio's car and brilliantly film it
because it'll look so awesome in their
court hearing as we cut to a security
camera showing them driving off okay
seriously are you just a shame that
professional cameras filmed your movie
did you see Blair Witch and we're like
dole we got a half assed it a lot more
get this they go to the location and
find another piece of the robot which
gives them a clue to the location where
the next piece is so glad dad spent all
his time devising this Easter egg hunt
instead of I don't know keeping their
future financially secure hey Frank
look I invented the smartphone I'm gonna
use it to cut vegetables my job to keep
an eye on you remember but real finds
them is surprisingly not turning them in
Korean Theft Auto is just girl's hand
fun but it looks like they might be
busted because they're trespassing jump
we jump come on you gotta jump something
I'm not afraid people say after watching
this movie thank God the air tight
perfection of a trash bag kept psynergy
dry because now he can jam with
everybody we got hard
me and you just wing to my strings do
you think Synergy's proud with this role
do you think he brings it up at family
get-togethers so they get ready for
their first big concert
hey Heights energy you don't want to
make the money and it just happens to be
at the same place where the next clue is
coinkidink perfect second lean your
weight on the back of your legs smile
but don't make faces paparazzi are not
your friends tell them all this a little
before they're about to step out into
the spotlight oh by the way you're not
singing you're actually juggling
chihuahuas ah well unfortunately the
power goes off spared no expense but
everyone gets out their phones and they
just keep the party going because they
love it so much
okay none of us left batteries to call
our parents for ride home but at least
we can barely hear what you're singing
over everyone after the show they locate
yet another clue and plug it in this
energy sure cuts your father if you're
hearing this I've been murdered
don't trust your aunt doesn't seem to
give him any answers so Jim just views
out some random we each have a
rhythm inside of us our heart beating it
connects us all so in the path you're on
allows you to hear it for the first time
it's like the whole world suddenly falls
into perfect harmony uh follow your
heart listen to your dreams remember to
brush your teeth I've other daily quota
emails so everyone seems to be in love
with Jim's amazingness please everyone
who was still under contract with
Universal at the time
Gemini did it for like six weeks is
pretty serious I'm totally working it
into the title of my next film Jurassic
statutory but it looks like there's bad
news on the horizon Jarek I lost the
appeal we just have till the end of this
week okay I have a robot with
consciousness we will be money
if I can get it to the right people oh
for God's sake
solo contract let me turn you into an
icon robot
you're really gonna sign with a person
who is doing everything she can to
convince you she is literally the devil
otherwise you would leave me no choice
but to replace you
oh excuse me those always pop up so
after signing it her legal name I'm sure
she clearly goes to tell her sisters
about it right nope she figures let it
be a surprise surely nothing bad would
come of it in the near future we were
just talking about you yeah we know we
heard everything
you signed a contract that
completely screws you over
you really are an Internet star I'm done
there of course pissed off if she tried
to save her house but of course they all
should be pissed off they're not using
that damn robot okay dead horse
nevertheless she gets dressed up as lady
haha and lets these background dancers
do God knows what
[Music]
we got our training by watching monkeys
do interpretive dance if you have a seat
right in the middle of the theater we
look amazing if not we just look really
awkward and confused but we know you're
used to watching that in this movie
anyway if not call this number together
we can heal
[Music]
you
so Lane runner part eights and all the
classic rock star cliches throwing stuff
off the desk look at yourself in a
cracked mirror referencing bands better
than her to make you think she's
somewhat like them in July 1973 the
Everly Brothers self destructed in front
of a sold-out crowd and happens bands
break up but we were supposed to be
different yeah that whole one show you
girls did together really cemented your
staying power go he's supposed to be
different that's probably the fastest
breakup ever recorded in human history
no matter you're late to your biggest
cliche finding the old house you grew up
in and sighing followed by the cliche
that her sister Kimber is there at the
exact same time and her foster sisters
Henry oh - you know why you're at it why
don't you just bring the dead father
back to meet him there - and how do they
solve all this conflict that's come
between them in literally one day how
else
[Music]
yep this is literally so stupid that
even the film calls itself out on it
okay that was weird as well as lazy
contrived and all-around unpleasant but
come on gang we still have a mystery to
solve
you see they discovered the entire
hologram messages in the star earrings
that gem has Wow so they have to break
into starlight studios to get so rather
than oh just walk in because she's their
biggest name and he's son of the owner
they disguised themselves to sneak
inside did you hear that door slam Fred
oh so about that talking Fred no not
even the from closing friend look it's
Jim in the Holograms I've blocked out
all visuals and sounds during this area
friend if you do you're not doing it
right
this leads to yet another YouTube video
that in no way connects to anything I
don't get it I really don't get it
except apparently this one has Rob
Scallon
like fat Rob Scallon what the hell is he
doing in this this is where I'm giving
him a call
hello Scallon why did you ever tell me
you're in Jem and the Holograms look uh
remember when I told you I did some
movies in the past that I wasn't very
proud of oh my god I thought you were
just talking about porn no it's far
worse
it was gem Rob had no idea it was hard
times and I let people use me in a way
that well I might never feel clean again
were you at least safe oh yeah I use
protection I had a lawyer look over the
contract oh good
here's so many things going around just
know that even though I've been through
a lot and you may never look at me the
same way again I'm still the same man I
was before wait a minute are you playing
your own sad music to manipulate me
gotta go so they're afraid the security
cameras might spot them but it's okay
because they put a video of a squirrel
jet skiing on and it actually works
Nolan
Robbins ejectives Alec it's a squirrel
what are we doing I'm not in the film or
the story just what are we doing as a
species what kind of mental illness was
going on through the writers mind the
only way this would be okay as if the
writer was like and then they had to
figure out how to get inside so they
used a squirrel anyway but it's okay
because they just want past the gars
with no problem anyway so this entire
break-in was all pointless my daughter
would kill me if I didn't get an
autograph if she says it's new let it go
really yeah
her words on my present yeah one of the
many lies this movies been telling you
they put the final piece in synergy and
yeah you sure you're dead didn't return
to his home planet when I found out how
little time I had left
I knew I needed to leave you something
not instructions on how to patent the
artificial life I created but rather a
scavenger hunt that hopefully you have
way too much time on your hands to
complete to try to teach you the lessons
that I most wanted to pass on lessons on
how to find random and sort out
simple clues seriously an episode
scooby-doo could have done that I wish I
could be there with you and in my heart
you'll always be my Jim I love you Jared
I love you too dad oh and tell your
sister she's cool too I guess
yeah kinda screwing Kimber over on all
this isn't he this wasn't just playing
favorites this is playing together a
league I'll screw you thankfully Kimber
wasn't in the room when he completely
forgets her existence and Jim wraps up
her quote-unquote confession I promised
you the truth and a confession of who I
really am yeah I was shocked this girl
rock star was a girl rock start wait
what am I supposed to learn so this
two-hour confession that apparently her
band mates were just listening quietly
to the whole time gets deleted and has
never shown to a solitary soul not that
I don't wish everything in this film
could be a race but what was the point
of all that instead she goes on stage to
pretty much just say the exact same
thing except shorter and dress like data
from first contact Jen is anybody who
has something that they want to express
and they need the courage to let
themselves be heard yes share that
message about being yourself
in a film that clearly has nothing to do
with Jim on top of that wheel discovers
his father's will
yeah guess he died of that fatal just be
dead ptosis as Jim's dad and it turns
out he left in the company so Erica is
out remove miss Raymond from the
that'll teach you from making us famous
bitch
so what's the first thing he's gonna do
now that the girls have agreed to make
decisions together and always be equal
totally rename the band without
consulting them about Gemma in the
hologram I figure a matches their
flakies see through almost invisible
personalities but after the movies
credits Erica plots her revenge and goes
to a band called the misfits you wish no
this is the rival band that always hated
Jem one of the few things they
spontaneously out of nowhere wanted to
make very similar to the cartoon destroy
Jen our songs are better we're gonna get
her why don't you go ahead and join us
Ulla in Last Airbender - I'm sure you'll
have plenty of time to talk about things
but even then there's one more thing to
talk about I want to sleep until the end
because it's a pretty big deal you're
probably wondering outside of giving us
an insulting Li week story and
characters explaining how to not be a
corporate sellout well be one of the
biggest corporate sellouts of all time
and having virtually nothing to do with
the show whatsoever how can they
possibly insult the fans even further
well you see the makers of this movie
actually offered the fans a chance to be
in the movie all they have to do is film
themselves saying how much they loved
Jem the cartoon tell us what you love
about Jem you can even post pictures of
you dressed up for whatever it is we
want to see and hear your passion for
the original jacket good idea I get the
buzz going maybe play it in the end
credits or something but that's not what
they do they take the footage of a fan
saying how much they loved the cartoon
and they edited to look like they're
talking about the gem from the movie a
movie nobody had seen by that point and
has little to do with the show they love
but now it looks like they're praising
the hell out of it I extract
with my ideas of beauty she stands out
and very humble which inspired me I just
want to say thank you for that Wow
that is low oh you like the cartoon you
think she's truly outrageous well this
is what you were talking about the whole
time yeah yeah this is gem fidget you
said it you basically taught me that
it's okay to be who you are and not to
be afraid I'm not invisible that I have
a voice oh you felt a strong emotional
bond well it's not the cartoon it's this
Jim this is the gem you felt a strong
emotional bond for this is like asking
people to make videos saying why they
love Star Wars and then suddenly editing
it to make it look like you're talking
about the Phantom Menace it's not just
cruel it's a slap in the friggin face
what makes it even funnier is how lazy
it is not only do they have the text of
the cartoon all over their stuff not
only are they dressed up like the
cartoon characters and not the movie but
you can see the cartoon playing in the
background yeah
they just let that in it's so clear what
they're talking about how amazingly lazy
can you get people as someone that
didn't watch Jim growing up and only
kind of saw it once in a while and
passing even I can say this movies an
insult it goes out of its way to piss
you off in every conceivable fashion it
doesn't work as a standalone film it
doesn't work as an adaptation the
choices make no sense and it does
everything in its power to make sure the
fans will hate it look I'm not gonna add
like I enjoyed this stupid cartoon we
all had our shows that only existed to
sell toys I had mine you had your ism
that's fine but there is a definite
audience that grew up with this and
while I know there has to be changes
when adapting a show to film there is
absolutely no respect and no love for
any of the people that grew up with it
so much what about transformers but it
had transformers this has no gel and
they're strangely proud of that well I
mean it is I know funny just what a
reckless sellout it is it does cross a
sort of line when it's taking fans of
the show and manipulating their footage
to
and something that they know they're
gonna hate it not only feels forced and
stupid it just feels wrong and I can see
now why you're trying to make my movie
you look like gem but cartoon it's a way
back all the fans that you lost
shut your non studio sanction mouth
critic yes we've destroyed much bigger
franchises than yours oh yeah who you
can't get to replace me
damn dams excitement Luton she's flashy
and things like that
fashion glitter hey guys this wig kind
of itches well melts excitement blue
mouse questions like that did we were on
anything at all I hope not
[Music]
you
no one probably to check this out it's a
squirrel
coming next week it's the Cat in the Hat
versus the Grinch the dr. Seuss special
everybody forgets about but you can see
it now under vessels ad free early
access just three dollars a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the release scoop hey Doug
Walker here doing the charity shout out
this week we are doing Direct Relief
this is a medical aid organization
active in all 50 states and in 70
countries with a mission to improve the
health and lives of people affected by
poverty or emergency situations this is
the first nonprofit organization the
u.s. to be designated by the National
Association of boards of pharmacy as a
verified accredited wholesale
distributor it's among the largest
medical suppliers to West Africa in
response to the Ebola epidemic the
Philippines following typhoon Haiyan and
Haiti after the 2010 quake it's also
earned a 100 percent fundraising
efficiency rating from Forbes
topping charity navigators 2015 list of
the top 10 best charities everyone's
heard of and it's named by the Fast
Company among the world's most
innovative companies for nonprofit these
are people that do wonderful work and
share amazing stories if you go to
either their site or their YouTube page
definitely check them out show your
support and help save the lives of so
many people in trouble the tiniest
little bit can go a long way
you
[Music]